ceo maurice benvenuti in questo
nuovissimo
allora ormai è risaputo non esiste una
festività senza un top flop di marina
quindi anche per questa pasqua mi sono
sentita in dovere di proporvi la mia
pasqua top e flop
in particolare voglio raccontarvi due
episodi di pasqua assolutamente flop e
uno di pasqua top
iniziamo subito la mia prima pasqua flop
poi ce ne sono state altre sempre uguali
adesso capirete per te risale alle
elementari
alimentari andavo dalle suore e dalle
suore puntualmente a pasqua si faceva la
recita di pasqua dove ognuno di noi di
tutte le classi di prima seconda terza
quarta quinta interpretava un
personaggio
inutile dirvi che se eri femmina il
personaggio più ambito era chiaramente
maria inutile dirvi che era il mio sogno
fare maria inutile dirvi che non ho mai
fatto
perché
mia mamma aveva avuto la brillante idea
di portarmi a tagliare i capelli da una
scuola di parrucchieri
e chiaramente mi è capitata
l'apprendista negata proprio che penso
che sia stato il suo unico giorno di
lavoro dove che è stata centrata
mia rasato i capelli
e l'ho chiesto un caschetto cantonata
casa coi capelli a spazzola per colpa di
questo taglio come dire poco femminile
la parte di maria non l'ho mai potuta
fare perché chiaramente c'era la mia
compagna di classico i capelli fino alle
ginocchia che era perfetta e voi direte
va beh avrei fatto un'altra parte
comunque carino
volete sapere che parti ho fatto per
tutti i cinque minuti
[Musica]
l'istigatrice del popolo e voi vi direte
ma che parte niente devo andare
praticamente tra la folla e dire questa
frase
portate barabba votate barabba questo è
quello che dice allora sono tra
documentari perché non ricordavo più
niente praticamente barabba
era come riportato in alcuni manoscritti
del vangelo un ebreo appartenente al
partito degli zeloti detenuto dai romani
a gerusalemme assieme ad alcuni ribelli
negli stessi giorni della passione di
gesù detto il cristo e fondatore del
cristianesimo
egli è bene liberato dalla folla ed è lì
che interveniva io l'istigatrice della
folla quindi praticamente io dicevo
votate barabba per liberarlo e penso di
sì e luisa come parte cioè mi veniva a
letto con una bella parte e roero contro
gesù quindi forse con me c'erano questi
due
appunto ebrei che dovevano uno dei due
doveva essere crocifisso secondo me e
quindi io dicevo voltate barabba per non
concepirlo quindi per per salvarlo e
nomination nomination vabbè chiusa
questa infelice parentesi delle recite
scolastiche passerei a una par con un po
più recente ma non recentissima forse
sei anni fa
vivevo ancora torino è praticamente
non avevo programmi per pasco perché ero
in un momento un po di ribellione non
volevo passarlo con la famiglia e volevo
fare qualcosa di alternativo
volevo fare una tasca un po alternativa
perché come dice il detto natale con i
tuoi pasqua con chi vuoi quindi io e la
mia migliore amica dei tempi siamo
guardate abbiamo detto ma cosa facciamo
per quasco facciamo qualcosa che non fa
nessuno
andiamo alle terme
ecco rivedibile concetto di non lo fa
nessuno perché vi ricordo che tutte
prese bene pronti a rilassarci a
staccare dal mondo arriviamo alle terme
c'era la coda fuori c'è una cosa mai
vista prima tutti quell'anno password
non dati alle terme quindi non vi
consiglio di andare mai all'eterna
pasqua in quel periodo ero innamorata
persa di un ragazzo quindi ci sentivamo
ogni tanto uscivamo però sapete quella
situazione in cui comunque non lui non
si espone più di tanto quindi non puoi
dire stiamo insieme a una frequentazione
nella quale io ero completamente
sotto un treno
arriviamo alle terme io mi metto il mio
costume eccetera eccetera quando si fa
le terme non so voi ma io non è che mi
mettono qualcosa sul più bello e metto
costume che anche se lo rovino
sono tranquilla praticamente era un
costume di merda e mi sono molto pentita
di questa scelta quando
appena entrata davanti a me vedo grazie
a dio lui non mi ha visto
lui
con una ragazza ed è subito panico
a quel punto ho detto allora o me ne
frego anche se sto rosicando un sacco e
continuo la mia pasqua bellissima alle
terme con altre 40 miliardi di persone
la mia migliore amica oppure trovo una
soluzione cosa faccio quando sui suoi
social e vedo che lui ladri faricciotti
do che avrebbe passato la pasquali
quindi mi sono fatta il viaggio
paranoico damon è che questo pensa che
io sia andata alle terme per
pedinarlo perché i veramente era da
stalker numero uno
quindi cosa ho fatto dopo aver pagato 50
euro di entrata di terme già vestita
come già col mio costumino pronta per
tuffarmi nell'idromassaggio
ho convinto la mia amica ad andarcene
perché non potevo rischiare di fare una
figura del genere non potevo numero
veramente drammatica
ma passiamo argomento top e sono sicuro
che di scendere una lacrima perché è un
momento molto recente si tratta di due
anni fa e come tanti di voi già sapranno
due anni fa
mi sono fidanzata con salvo
cosa è successo due anni fa a pasqua è
successo che
ero tornata a vivere momentaneamente a
torino
perché finita l'università non trovavo
lavoro e quindi per non pesare appunto
sui miei chiedo non pagare un affitto a
vuoto me ne sono tornata a torino è però
ormai avevo tutti gli amici qua
dell'università c per accedere quindi
venivo spesso qua a milano e dormivo a
casa dei miei amici quindi anche quella
pasqua proprio come quella del mio della
mia pasqua flop non avevo voglia insomma
di passarlo in famiglia volevo un attimo
dell'ira milano magari di festeggiare
fare qualcosa di diverso e quindi ho
sentito questo mio compagno
all'università ex compagno sita proprio
mal avevano finito vita che mi dice
marina guarda se ti va bene anche su mia
sorella dalla sicilia siamo un po qua
faccio una pasquetta qua sono anche
degli altri amici che insomma verranno a
fare la pasqua qua siamo tutti insieme
ci divertiamo da ieri io non avendo
tante altre opzioni perché tutte le mie
amiche o lo facciamo ancora famiglia oi
fidanzati io come al solito ero single
ho detto va bene ci sto
quindi prendo il mio treno vengo a
milano prima cosa ti faccio ancora prima
di posare le valigie e andare in centro
a comprarmi dei nuovi vestiti e li sento
il mio amico che mi dice guarda c'è mia
sorella in giro ben capito lei così vi
vedete tornare venite a casa insieme
che con un mio amico
tutto va bene becco sua sorella in
centro e mi accorgo che il suo amico io
lo conoscevo già e l'avevo conosciuto in
sicilia perché
la maggior parte dei miei
diversità ri era veniva dalla sicilia e
quindi puntualmente io quasi tutte le
estati scendeva giù e andavo a trovarli
e quindi
conoscevo anche comunque altri loro
amici che non vivevano abbiano però
scendevano come tutti i fuori sede in
sicilia d'estate e avevo conosciuto
questo ragazzo in discoteca ma proprio
tipo ciao piace piacere fine
molto carino molto bello ai tempi era
fidanzato io pure e niente quindi lago
conosciuto dopo tipo 12 anni non mi
ricordo chi io lui non lo ammette però
come era stato lui ad aggiungere mi su
facebook perché io proprio per principio
odio aggiungere i ragazzi su facebook
cioè mi sento veramente nelle provata
quindi non l'ho mai fatto accettavo solo
le richieste di quelli che se mi
sembravano carini lui appena l'ho visto
lo avevo già conosciuto l'ho accettato e
quindi da lì non è che ci sentivamo prof
6 ogni tanto ci mettevamo un like e
tattico questa persona era salvo
[Musica]
che quando lo vedo davanti però
anche tu qui bene io non ne sapevo nulla
infatti poi mi sono mezzo incazzata col
mio amico perché le toccava potevi dire
di canali già lo conoscevo
nel senso potevo decidere se venire o
meno da te per pasqua
magari non sarei venuto
ok detto questo lo vedo ci salutiamo
eccetera eccetera e poi andiamo a casa
praticamente cosa è successo che per non
mi ricordo cinque sei giorni a settimana
abbiamo anche una specie di grande
fratello perché eravamo io il mio amico
sua sorella salvo e i due coinquilini
del nemico e le rispettive fidanzate o
comunque amici dei due con corini quindi
abbiamo fatto praticamente un grande
fratello in questi giorni di grande
fratello a pasqua pasquetta non mi
ricordo ho avuto la brillanti le a dire
ragazzi oggi cucino io e già li dovevano
aver paura
perché ho detto già ci piace chiamo io
salgo se lo prendo per la gola come
tutti gli uomi calder ai miei piedi o
faccio cucino mio piatto forte che sono
gli gnocchi ai formaggi non brucio la
pentola
cioè erano voli tutti che
chiacchieravamo erano si stavano facendo
un certo punto si chiama la puzza di
bruciato immensa ha preso fuoco la
pentola cioè con una figura di merda
atroce niente
c'era creazione io facevo latina dove
sempre uno due tre quattro giorni e poi
noto al momento del primo bacio primo
bacio è stato
molto molto molto molto difficile
perché lui voleva baciare meglio testina
testina destino e strade stina
chiaramente devo fare un pò la ritrosa
non potevo cedere così e alla fine c'è
stato questo primo bacio è praticamente
nessuno aveva voglia di uscirne vogliamo
andare a ballare sai fare un po di night
life nessuno le voci e quindi non ho mai
capito se l'hanno fatto apposta per
lasciarci soli oppure se era veramente
se non avevamo veramente vogliono uscire
se hai fatto che io stavo prendiamo la
macchina l'enjoy e ce ne andiamo in un
locale in corso como chi le amicizie
andiamo a bere
[Musica]
nord ma io lo chiamavo amo perché io
chiamo amo tutti eravamo in macchina
continuo dire amo cioè lo trattavo un po
tipo così tipo da amico perché io
comunque gli amici li chiamo così duro e
ha ceduto luis igienica mano cosa
scusa io chiamo a1 chi voglio io chiamo
amo tutti quindi fatto notare denti
momento anno arriviamo in questo locale
mente beviamo sente la musica così e ci
conoscevamo un po c'è parti ci
raccontavamo chi eravamo e
cosa volevamo dalla vita al giorno punto
questo momento filosofico si avvicina
una
che si pianta davanti a me ci abita le
spalle e si mette a parlare con lui
chiedendole un accendino
il commovente marina doveva scegliere
tra
ucciderla
oppure fare la parte di quella che
comunque non era interessata era con
un'amica aveva alcun problema
non l'ho uccisa chiaramente poi momento
io ho avuto la brillante idea di e ligia
senti allora non so come andrà a finire
tra di noi magari non ci vedremo mai più
però sappi che avevo detto così se io
fossi la tua fidanzata lo sai che in
questo momento con la tipa cioè avrebbe
finito di esistere
e allora lui se ne sa ridere perché
anche se io in girata così comunque era
una mezza roba tipo che ero gelosa o no
che non so da dove mi è uscita però io
sono così sono sincera quindi avrei
detto cavolo se stavamo insieme queste
si mette acqua davanti a spostava
diciamo senti in via ci sono anch'io
cioè ferite non accennino quest'anno
aggravanti avete trovati davanti ok è di
3 watt in aria non è il posto per te
quindi già avevo capi aveva capito già
la tipologia di ragazzo ecco e diciamo
che con questa uscita salvo ha iniziato
a capire insomma che non mi era
indifferente
anche perché dai miei comportamenti
cercavo di fargli capire che non era
coinvolta no sai facevo testina così c'è
perché io sono un po diffidente
all'inizio non mi sciolgo subito lì non
so perché forse era stato l'alcol e l'ho
buttata li tieni questo è quello che
penso e io ti può forse gelo dopo si
sono pentite però ormai dado era tratto
quello che è successo dopo che è stato
anche abbastanza complicato ci stara
dovrei fare un video lungo e raccontarvi
tutto nei dettagli quindi la chiudiamo
qui e ne parleremo più avanti ve lo
prometto che prima o poi vi racconterò
tutto tutto tutta la storia detto questo
spero che il video vi sia piaciuto come
al solito se non l'avete ancora fatto
iscrivetevi al canale e cliccate sulla
campanella vicino al tasso d'iscrizione
per ricevere una notifica tutte le volte
che pubblicherò un nuovo video e
soprattutto seguite vi su tutti gli
altri social instagram facebook e
musicali io vi mando un bacione e vi
faccio tanti tanti tanti auguri di una
buona pasqua ci vediamo al prossimo
miglior adoro
[Musica]